Wir wollen sprechen über den europäischen Top-Fußball bei den Männern. Wir sprechen heute über Spanien, England, Italien und über die Ähre de Vigée, also die Niederlande. Jetzt hier mit Daniel Zander, Christian Bernhard, Nies Kern und Uli Hebel kommt auch noch mit dazu. Was für ein Setup. Los geht's. Und nun im Programm der Rasenfunk.
Der Blick auf andere Ligen.
Hallo und herzlich Willkommen liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Ein Tag später als geplant. Also ich hoffe zumindest, dass ich das hier einen Tag später als geplant veröffentlicht habe. Wir wissen es alle noch nicht. Es muss ein bisschen improvisiert werden aktuell beim Rasenfunk. Ich entschuldige mich dafür und wir machen es wett, indem wir jetzt lieber gleich in ein Thema reinstarten, bevor wir hier die Aufnahme wieder unterbrechen müssen. Nils, wenn du magst, dann leg du doch mal los. Was hast du uns aus Spanien mitgebracht? Und schön, dass du hier bist.
Und könnten jetzt Arsenal so richtig schlechte Laune dann besorgen, rund um Weihnachten, rum die Vorweihnachten, ist es noch erst im Pokal und dann in der Liga? Einmal ausfahrt, einmal zu Hause.
Wäre der absolute Klassiker. Verarsene. Oder ist es fast schon wieder zu billig ist.
Ich hab's gesehen, dachte mir so, oh oh. Na gut, wir schauen uns an, was da passiert. Aber schön zu hören, dass es bei Crystal Palace wieder ein bisschen positiverer Schlagzeilen zu berichten gibt, das freut alle Fans von Oliver Glasner. Dann machen wir nochmal eine schnelle Runde. Nils, was hast du uns noch mitgebracht?
Ja, früher war das ja die Kategorie Unsung Hero. Und jetzt kommt natürlich einer, der durchaus im Matridismo besungen wird. Na na na na na na na. Hey Jude, der aber in der Öffentlichkeit noch ein bisschen so hinterfragt wird, warum ist die die Tor-Serie von der letzten Hinrunde nicht mehr da? Ist er irgendwie im Formloch? Nö, Jude Bellingham hat einfach primär letzte Rückrunde, linkes Mittelfeld gespielt, nicht mehr so nah an der Box, auch weil Ancelotti mehr Offensivoptionen hatte. Und das war auch ein bisschen zu Beginn dieser Saison der Fall, als dann eben neben Wini und Rodrigo dann auch noch diese eine Franzose aus dem Rasenfunk-Intro eingesetzt wurde. Aber auch das ist jetzt die letzten Wochen, hat sich das ein bisschen geändert. Jude Bellinghams Knoten ist endlich geplatzt. Das war gegen OstraZuna, da war ich selbst noch dabei. Da hat er getroffen, jetzt so aus den letzten sieben Spielen, sechs Tore und drei Vorlagen. Und dann hätte er auch noch ein Elfmeter Liverpool schießen können, auch ein Elfmeter in Bilbao schießen können, aber hat da den bestimmten Franzosen den Vorzug gelassen. Also was ich sagen will, Jude Bellingham ist eigentlich schon auch das ganze Kalenderjahr gut, weil er sehr viel arbeitet, sehr viel ausstrahlt von der Körpersprache. Auch mal ein bisschen Gegenspieler anschnauzt oder ein bisschen hinterfragt, warum jetzt da der Laufweg oder das Gegenpressing nicht gekommen ist. Also er ist da schon auch extrem ehrgeizig, so kennt man ihn aus der Bundesliga, aber das wird schon durchaus positiv, in positive Energie umgewandelt im Madridismo oder generell auch in der Presse, dass es da nicht zu Polemikas kommt, wie Bellingham schnauzt Guller an, sondern Bellingham spornt Guller an, noch mehr zu machen und er hat dann auch das Tor gemacht und klar, von dem her ist da Bellingham gerade so ein bisschen unbesogen, weil ich glaube immer noch in der Öffentlichkeit viele denken, ja der ist das, der hat das war noch eine Ausnahme seine Hinrunde und jetzt danach ist er nichts mehr bei der Madrid. Nee, der ist ziemlich viel und jetzt kommen aktuell auch wieder die Torbeteiligung zurück.
Der wirkt ja auf mich wahnsinnig überspielt, sowohl schon in Teilen der Rückrunde, bei der EM hast du es dann in den guten Phasen nicht gesehen, aber in den schlechteren Phasen und es hing ja wahnsinnig viel an Bellingham bei England, bei dieser EM und dann kam er ja verletzt daraus, also eigentlich scheint es für mich eine total logische Entwicklung zu sein, der braucht ein bisschen Anlaufzeit und jetzt kommt er wieder langsam an sein altes Niveau heran, aber es gab trotzdem, das habe ich richtig verstanden, schon kritische Stimmen ihm gegenüber.
Nee, also bei Fans eher, die sich dann wundern, warum er keine Tore macht und man hat ihn doch geholt, um Tore zu machen, nee eben nicht, er ist halt ein sehr kompletter Mittelfeldspieler, der auch sehr viel arbeitet und kämpft und immer das Trikot irgendwie schmutzig hat und was so angesprochen hat, es so überspielt, Verletzung ist auch eine Wahrheit, bei ihm ist auch wieder so ein bisschen so eine alte Schulterverletzung aufgebrochen, man sieht bei ihm unter dem Trikot immer so eine schwarze Schutzweste, also das schleppt er noch ein bisschen mit sich rum und trotzdem auch ein zu 90 Prozent fitter Bellingham ist aktuell so der beste Matrilene oder in dieser Saison Top 3, weil er wie gesagt auch als einer von wenigen sehr viel Biss zeigt auf dem Platz und nicht immer nur alles so geschehen lässt und einfach auch sehr viel im Pressing wichtig ist, was bei Real ziemlich random ist und wir aber er zumindest gibt er immer noch Druck und er hat mittlerweile auch das Glück vom Tor wieder neun Torbeteiligung aus jetzt sieben Spielen ist schon ist da kein Zufall.
Aber wirklich.
Soll nicht ganz unwichtig sein auch für große Spieler, dass sie eine gute geordnete Vorbereitung haben, um langsam in Form zu kommen.
Amen.
Aber wir sind ja immer alle so ungeduldig, wir Beobachtenden. Daniel, was hast du noch in der Eredivisie für uns?
Ich hab was von Arsett Alkmaar mitgebracht und zwar Sven Meinanz. Das ist ja quasi auch so ein Ansagen hier. Bei Arsett ist es wieder eigentlich unfassbar, was da für Nachwuchsarbeit geleistet wird. Der Fokus liegt so ein bisschen auf Rüben van Bommel, das ist auch der Sohn von Marc van Bommel oder Kay Smeet zum Beispiel, der echt auch herausragend in den letzten Spielen abstrahliert hat auch international, trotz der roten Karte gegen Istanbul. Und er geht zumindestens seinen Meinanz unter. Der ist Zehner von Haus aus, hat aber mittlerweile, könnte man sagen, Polyvalent, als Sport, weil er auch mittlerweile zugezogen reagiert als Achter. Die letzten beiden Spiele war er Sechser, aber hat das gut gemacht und hat so ein bisschen so typische Box-to-Box-Qualitäten an den Tag gelegt, was sich halt auch an seinen relativ geringen Scoring-Punkten zeigt. Er hat jetzt drei Tore. Das ist in 15 Spielen für einen Zehner jetzt nicht unbedingt viel, aber es ist eben dann auch so wie bei Jude, weil er eben nicht nur an diesen Toren gemessen werden sollte, sondern eben auch an der Leistung fürs Team. Und der SS24 ist aber für das Alter auch schon relativ reif. Er ist auch fiese Kapitän gewesen, als der etatmäßige Jordi Klaasie mal rausgefallen ist, die Bünde übernommen. Er hat sich im Interview schützend vor seine Mitspieler gestellt, unter anderem vor Kees Meade, der diese gelb-rote gesiebert hat in der EL gegen Istanbul. Hat er auch gesagt, ja, passieren und er übernimmt viel Verantwortung und hat eben sportlich auch andere Qualitäten als nur die reinen Scorer-Punkte, weil er eben auch so ein bisschen das Herzstück stellt von AZ, da viele kluge Pässe einleitet. Und im Eishockey hat man ja oft diese Vor-Vor-Vorlage, diese dritte Vorlage.
Im Fußball ist es der Toni Kroospass.
Genau, der Toni Kroospass. Und Sven Meydans macht sehr viele Toni Kroospässe, die dann eben nicht in der Statistik auftauchen, die aber natürlich auch für das Kriieren von Torschancen, für das Einleiten von gefährlichen Aktionen einfach elementar sind. Und da ist er auch ein sehr starker Spieler und ist mit, wie gesagt, seinen 24 Jahren noch jung, noch sehr entwicklungsfähig, aber eben schon auf einem sehr guten Level, weil er sich eben auch anpassen kann, flexibel ist. Ich glaube, rechts außen war er auch schon mal die Saison. Demek leider der Mittelfeld, einfach sehr viel Position. Und das geht so ein bisschen unter, weil der Fokus bei AZ gerne auf diesen noch jüngeren Talenten liegt, wie Van Bommel oder wie KS Smith. Oder eben auf Parrot, den Stürmer, den ich auch schon mal hier, glaube ich, angeblich hatte. Und deswegen würde ich mal so ein bisschen das Licht auf Sen Mainans riechen.
Schön, dazu viel AZ-Liebe aus Italien auch rübergeschickt. Ich sag nur rein, dass zum Cob Mainas.
Oh ja, guter Ex-Vorschlager.
Hätten wir eine eigene Ligatur mal verdient. Das ist total, was da rumläuft an Talenten, das ist nicht normal, diese Youth-Sieger-Mannschaft von 22, Max Merding, hört sich an wie ein WWE-Wrestler, aber es ist so ein Firmino-Regent-Quarkmann, so quasi die Jungtyp.
Quarkmann, ja.
Und ein Aufregerspieler, dann gibt's noch den, der ist der krasseste von allen, Masterras, der ist glaube ich erst 17 oder so was. Also richtig gut.
Und das Erstaunliche ist auch, dass die relativ nahtlos, wenn sie in die Profiteam kommen, zu den ersten Herren kommen, funktionieren. Und das ist echt, hatten ja auch nicht immer so klappraundige Zeit, aber so ein Case Meet, die hatte man jetzt auch nicht seit Längerem auf dem Schirm. Und dann kommt die aber hoch und funktioniert relativ geordnet, macht auch seine Spiele, spielt international und macht das für das Alter schon gut. Und das ist von so einem Phänomen, dass man bei AZ eigentlich bei sehr, sehr vielen Spielern aus der eigenen Jugend hat. Und das ist ja auch das Geschäftsmodell quasi jetzt endlich von AZ, diese Talente dann eben zu verkaufen für viel Geld. Und dieses Geld wird dann eben auch nicht nur auf Markt investiert, sondern eben auch in Infrastruktur, eben auch in die Nachricht Akademie. Und das zahlt sich aus und das ist für viele auch in der R&D Vita selbst ein Vorbildsverein.
Also da werden wir auf jeden Fall noch weitere Anzwang Heroes und MVP und so weiter oder wie auch immer wir es dann nennen werden diese Kategorie sehen. Arzett Aikma und Sven Meinanz. Merkt euch den Namen hier, habt ihr ihn vielleicht zum ersten Mal gehört. Christian, worüber möchtest du noch gerne sprechen?
Ich bringe euch noch eine Brüdergeschichte mit. Ich gebe ja bekannte Beispiele aus Italien, die Insagi-Brüder vielleicht an die sich ein paar noch erinnern. Die Baresi-Brüder wissen vielleicht nicht alle, dass Franco Baresi auch einen Bruder hatte, der auch noch bei Inter gespielt hat. Ist egal, ist die Vergangenheit. Wir gehen jetzt eine Stufe höher, denn ich komm jetzt mit den Espositos-Brüder vorbei und die sind nicht nur zwei, sondern die sind so dritt. Und die hatten am vergangenen Sonntag einen ziemlich witzigen Sonntag, denn die drei haben, ich würde sagen ihr Papa hatte den schönsten Nachmittag, denn die drei haben innerhalb von 45 Minuten fünf Tore erzielt. Und zwar fangen wir an, Sebastiano Esposito hat in der Serie A zwei Puden gemacht für Empoli auswärts bei Hellas. Riesentalent, an dem hat Inter immer noch die Transferrechte zuletzt immer ein bisschen verliehen worden, um Spielpraxis zu sammeln. Aber da ist Inter wie gesagt auf den Zehntes über möglich auch noch für die Zukunft. Und dann gehen wir in der Liga drunter und zwar bei Spezia, die auch Top 3 in der Liga sind, Aufstiegsmitfavorit. Das spielen die anderen zwei Brüder, nämlich Salvatore und Pio. Ja und die haben halt auch drei Puden insgesamt gemacht beim 5-0-Sieg. Also und die Torabfolge war wirklich so, dass innerhalb von 45 Minuten hat der Papa von den Espositors oder die ganze Familie halt fünf Tore bejubeln können. Und zu den zwei Spezia-Spieler muss man auch noch sagen, Salvatore, das ist der älteste von denen, ein U21-Nationalspieler, das ist ein Sechser, ganz solider Spieler. Ich glaube, der wird auch demnächst noch Serie A, glaube ich. Eine gewisse Rolle spielen jetzt vielleicht nicht ganz oben, aber solide. Und Pio, das ist der jüngste, der ist 18, ist ein Mittelstürmer, ziemlich kantig, bisschen anders als Sebastiano, der technisch sehr guter ist. Pio bringt viel Füße mit und der ist wirklich nur von Inter ausgeliehen, ist 18 und hat in der Saison schon in der Serie B acht Buden gemacht. Also das ist einer vielleicht auch die nächsten Jahre bei Inter, vielleicht Stürmer Nummer drei, Nummer vier. Also ja, behaltet euch der Esposito aus dem Kopf, wie gesagt, fünf Tore in 45 Minuten, würde ich auch sagen, nicht unbedingt alltäglich.
Aber wirklich die Esposito Brüder, man weiß nicht, ob es eine Folge von Narcos ist oder eben ein Thema in der Liga Tour. Jetzt sind wir uns ganz sicher. Uli, worüber möchtest du noch sprechen?
Ich würde wahrscheinlich noch gerne über Brentford sprechen wollen. Die haben ein ganz normales für sie Ergebnis geholt. Das ist sozusagen so was wie Tottenham, nur dass es immer gut ausgeht. 4-2 gegen Newcastle, also zumindest gemessen an den Erwartungen. Die sind einfach neunter in der Saison, haben 31 erzielte Tore und 28 kassierte. Also es passiert einfach immer was, wenn die spielen. Das war schon mal so ähnlich so, nur dass es meistens in die schlechte Richtung ging. Ich hatte die potenziell als einen möglichen Absteiger, wenn die Dinge sich schlecht entwickeln würden. Die haben ja Ivan Thony verloren, was im Nachhinein ein Segen ist. Das habe ich mir schon fast gedacht, aber ich hab nicht. Also die spielen eigentlich seit Jahren mit dem gleichen Kern, der auch aufgestiegen ist. Die sind alle zusammen älter geworden, ist aber auch eine schöne Geschichte. Es funktioniert aber. Und warum ich das mache ist, ist es ein Video, eineinhalb Minuten, zwei nur lang, rausgekommen, kann ich dir vielleicht schicken, dann Max, kannst du es vielleicht verlinken, wo man sieht wie Thomas Frank die Jungs dann direkt anspricht, wenn er in die Kabine kommt.
Habe ich sogar schon gesehen.
Zeigt diese unglaublich guten kommunikativen Fähigkeiten. Es ist nothing special was er da macht. Das ist eine ganz normale Ansprache an ein Team, aber ich habe mir das drei, viermal angeschaut, einfach auch nur auf verschiedene Dinge zu achten. A wie spricht er, nennt jeden Einzelnen, der gespielt hat, ganz kurz, aber auch die, die nicht spielen vor allen Dingen. Und man sieht, wenn er dann die einzelnen Spieler nennt, das Lächeln in den Gesichtern, aber vor allen Dingen rundherum auch die, wie sie darauf reagieren. Und da merkt man irgendwie, dass so Zusammenhalt da. Und ich würde vieles davon, und das weiß ich auch aus dem Verein heraus, auf die kommunikativen Fähigkeiten des Cheftrainers schicken, der glaube ich überdurchschnittlich begabt ist in dem Punkt. Und auch mit ganz einfachen Worten vieles richtig sagt. Und das ist wahrscheinlich ein singulärer Grund dafür, dass Brentford da oben steht. Deswegen wollte ich die einfach mal genannt haben.
So schön Uli, dass du sowas ansprichst, weil da vielleicht, hatte ich vorhin vergessen, dann kann man Baroni noch mal kurz reinnehmen. Es ist so schön, dass eben auch eine gute Kommunikation aus Trainersicht, wie du sagst, das muss ja kein Zauberwerk sein, aber es ist einfach kommunikativ gut, wie wichtig das ist. Ein Satz noch zu Baroni. Baroni wie gesagt, der sagt, das ist die Chance meines Lebens mit 61. Der hat vor kurzem auch mal erzählt, er schaut sich jede seiner eigenen Pressekonferenzen noch mal an und lässt die Revue passieren, weil er sagt, Kommunikation sowohl Richtung Außen als auch Journalisten, als auch Teamentdehren, als auch seine Ansprachen schaut er sich noch mal an, ist halt einfach unfassbar wichtig. Und da ist es so schön, wenn ich das höre, weil es halt auch Trainer gibt, die auch den Bereich, die wissen, dass das ein wahnsinnig wichtiger Punkt ist. Und noch mal, da reden wir jetzt nicht von Zauberei, oder du musst da nicht jede Woche die Ansprache des Lebens halten, sondern du musst einfach das Ganze gut empathisch machen. Und Baroni passt halt auch genau in die Riege rein, weil er sich einfach Gedanken dazu macht und das Ganze halt als wichtiges Thema aus der Korn hat. Deswegen, sorry dazu, das passt da wunderbar rein. Sehr schön, dass man so was hört.
Und in diesem Video, da siehst du vor allem die Wertschätzung für die Spieler, auch für die Spieler, die nicht gespielt haben, also dass er darauf eingeht. Und ganz ehrlich, ein Typ, der in der Premier League-Kabine steht und in einem leichten Akzent seine Spieler lobt und sich das anfühlt wie eine Familie. Ich hatte so harte Ted Lasso-Vibes. Das ist...
Du hattest gehofft, du sagst nicht Jürgen Klopp oder so.
Nein, komplett anders. Der hat ja vorher nicht irgendwie dem Schiedsrichterassistenten den Kopf abgebissen.
Das stimmt sogar, ja das stimmt sogar.
Also und ich hab noch ein anderes Video neulich von Thomas Frank gesehen, da hat er einfach darüber gesprochen, warum Distanzschüsse keinen Sinn ergeben, eben Expected Goals Werte, wie man sie vorbereiten kann und so weiter und so fort. Auch ganz ruhig, das war jetzt nichts besonderes, das war jetzt auch inhaltlich nicht so, dass man sich gedacht hat, oh das hab ich ja noch nie gehört im Fußball, aber einfach die Art und Weise, wie er das auf Augenhöhe mit dem Experten im Studio besprochen hat und aber auch selber jetzt nicht so getan hat, als ob er hier gerade Herrschaftswissen verteilt.
Ich hab das hier eh mal erzählt, wir waren kurz vor der Pandemie in England, haben damals Gott sei Dank noch das alte Stadion gesehen und haben da Thomas Frank auch sprechen können, weil er aber auf uns zukam. Also mein Bruder und mich, meine ich damit. Wir haben einfach sozusagen zwei Zweitligaspiele geguckt damals, unter der Woche sind dahin und ich hab ihm irgendeine Frage gestellt, da waren die schon so im Fringe-Aufstiegsrennen mit dabei und hab ihm eine Frage gestellt und haben wir uns dann um den Begriff Athletik und Dynamik gestritten und er wollte meine Definition von Athletik haben, dann hab ich ihm die gegeben und gesagt, ich würde nicht sagen, dass wir das athletischste Team der Liga sind, aber das dynamischste. Und dann hat er auf dieser Frage fünf Minuten rumgeritten, hat ihm total Spaß gemacht und dann kommt er, also damals in dem alten Stadion bei Brentford, das ist jetzt kein Pressekonferenzraum, sondern das war halt so das Sportheim von hinten. Dann ist er halt so reingebeten worden. Marcelo Bielsa im Übrigen war sein Gegner damals gegen Leeds und Marcelo Bielsa kam halt mit seinem mit seiner Entourage da rein, mit Übersetzer und so weiter. Und hat halt niemanden angeschaut in dem ganzen Raum. Wir saßen alle so da, also vor der Pandemie, muss man noch mal wissen, war im Nachhinein ein besonders behagliches Gefühl. Und da saßen wir alle so da und Marcelo Bielsa hat halt seine drei Fragen, die er halt machen musste und ist dann abgezogen. Ich habe es echt versucht, aber keine Chance. Und bei Thomas Frank war es so, der hat sich halt Zeit genommen, hat jeden einzelnen so mehr oder weniger begrüßt. Der kannte halt die ganzen anderen Typen da so und kannte halt auch so ungefähr die Fragen, die kamen und dann kamen halt meine. Und dann sind wir draußen gestanden, die Mixed Zone war hinter so einem Bauzaun und wir haben halt noch ein paar Leute gewartet. Und irgendwann kommt der auf uns zu und sagt, Jungs, wer seid denn ihr eigentlich? Und das ist halt einfach der Chef-Trainer. Und dann hab ich gesagt, ja wieso denn? Ja, weil so eine Frage hat er noch nie gehört. Die meisten wollen halt nur wissen Verletzungen und so Zeugs. Und dann hat er uns die Hand geschüttelt und gesagt, ja Deutschland, er spricht auch ein bisschen Deutsch, hat dann so zwei, drei Brocken halt raus und dann haben wir so fünf Minuten noch geredet und so weitergegangen. Hast du schon gemerkt, der ist irgendwie anders. Es ist special. In dem Punkt wenigstens.
Und da kann man auch Schulter am Schulter im Pressekonferenzraum sitzen und sich das sehr gerne anhören. Jetzt machen wir noch eine ganz schnelle Runde, dass wenn ich zu sehr über euer Zeitbudget drüber gehen Nies. Ich würde jetzt nicht sagen, du hast 30 Sekunden. Nee, Quatsch. Was ist denn das letzte Thema?
Schaff ich. Es ist eigentlich eine schöne Entwicklung, dass jetzt mehr und mehr Langzeitpatienten in La Liga zurückkehren. Wir hatten ja schon in den letzten Wochen einen Gavi bei Barca, der zurückgesetzt ist. Ronald Araucho stand wieder im Kader. David Alaba teilweise schon im Mannschaftstraining, auch wenn der wohl erst im Januar wieder eingesetzt wird. Und da gab es jetzt auch am Wochenende ein schönes Comeback bei Betis. Das war Isco, der hat wegen Wadenbeinbruch lange gefehlt. Und ja, La Liga ist natürlich auch von schweren Verletzungen nicht gefällt. Auch Dani Cavajal, Eder Militao und auch viele andere Kreuzbandrisse gibt es da. Aber es ist auch dann immer wieder mal zu schön zu sehen, dass es dann eben auch zu den erhofften Comebacks kommt. Und da habe ich jetzt natürlich auch viele vergessen, die da auch verletzt sind. Aber das ist eine nette Entwicklung und ich bin gespannt, wer jetzt als nächstes eine nette Geschichte noch raushauen kann. Wie hatten wir die Reihenfolge? Jetzt kam als nächstes Daniel, oder?
Genau. Ich mache noch ganz schnell zwei kleine Themen. Das eine ist der Europa Blues von Playzways zurück, der Europamythos. In der Liga dominieren sie eigentlich alles, haben mit 6 zu 1 gegen Trente gewonnen. Und gegen Press ist es mir unerklärlich, wie das verloren gegangen sein konnte. Die erste Halbzeit hatten sie unglaublich viele Chancen. In der zweiten Halbzeit war es da nicht mehr ganz so gut. Und das ist oft so ein Thema in der Rallye Divisi, dass die vor allem PSV Eindhoven in der Liga alles dominiert und dann gegen vermeintlich auf dem Papier etwa gleichwertige Gegner, wo man sagen muss, dass Press natürlich eine herausragende Saison spielt in der Champions League, dass das da eben nicht läuft. Und oft kriegen sie ihren Boschball nicht auf den Rasen. Jetzt am Dienstag eigentlich schon. Und trotzdem hatten sie einfach unglaublichen Chancenwucher, was sehr untypisch ist für PSV. Und das eigentliche Highlight oder Lowlight, wie man möchte, kam dann nämlich im Anschluss, nämlich auch Stichwort Kommunikation des Trainers, der öffentlich dann sehr ungehalten war und gesagt hat, das war der schlechteste Spiel, seitdem er dort Trainer ist. Seit der ersten Sekunde hätte ihm nichts gefallen an diesem Spiel, wo ich sage, so schlimm war es eigentlich gar nicht. Aber Peter Bosz war sehr ungehalten und das ist einfach so ein Mysterium in der Eredivisie, diese Unfähigkeit von Belswey, sage ich mal, dieses Unglück in der ECL einfach so aufzutreten, eben nicht wie in der Liga. Und das zweite kurze Ding, als schöner Rauschmeister der Eredivisie hatten wir ja zu Beginn das traurige Thema mit dem Sponsor-Namen ab der kommenden Saison der Liga. Aber es gibt auch eine gute Unterricht für alle Traditionistinnen, nämlich das alte Ajax-Logo kehrt zurück ab nächster Saison. Verabschiedet man sich von diesem sehr abstrakten Logo der letzten Jahre und geht zurück zu dem alten Logo, was bis zu den 90er Jahren auf der Post hängt, war auch ein großer Wunsch der Fans. Und es ist im Prinzip auch zum 125. Jubiläum von Ajax, was sie nächstes Jahr feiern. Der Anlass. Und das wird aber dauerhaft dann wieder auf die Tikus zu sehen sein. Das ist so ein schöner Abfluss für mich.
Aber wirklich, ich danke euch sehr, sehr herzlich, dass ihr das mal kurz hier in Eigenregie weiter gemacht habt. Ich hatte ja nach der Sendung, was hier gerade rauskam. Christian, welches Thema hast du noch dabei?
Ja, ich bringe noch eins. Wir sind ja nicht mehr so weit von Weihnachten entfernt. Dann bringe ich vielleicht eine kleine Geschichte, die ein bisschen herzerwärmt ist mit Fußball in Rom. Das ist eine Geschichte, die war ziemlich medial begleitet. 2019 war da ein Unfall, wo ein älterer Herr ins Koma gefallen ist, quasi als Autounfall. Und der hat dann, also den konnte sie aus dem Koma wieder hervorholen, aber der hat einfach 39 Jahre seines Lebens sozusagen, waren nicht mehr präsent. Also er ist 2019 ins Koma gefallen und das Letzte, was er sich erinnern konnte, war irgendwie im März Tag 1980. Und warum konnte er sich an den erinnern? Weil er ein großer Roma-Fan war. Und die Roma war damals in der Saison halt gut, ja, noch im Rennen. Und das war somit sein letzter Moment, den er sich erinnern konnte quasi. Und er hat dann, also es ist wirklich eine ganz berührende Geschichte, weil da kam dann zum Beispiel, als er aus dem Koma erwacht ist, kam seine Frau ans Bett und er hat gemeint, hä, wie, das kann nicht meine Frau sein, ich bin ja mit einer 19-Jährigen verlobt und wir sollten eigentlich ein paar Monaten heiraten. Und das war aber seine Frau. Er hat auch seinen Sohn nicht erkannt, weil sein Sohn erst später geboren ist. Und so, lange Rede kurze Sinde zur Einleitung. Und die Roma hat das jetzt zum Anlass genommen, weil er halt eben diesen tiefen Bezug hatte, ihn einzuladen, hat mit Ruggero Rozzitelli, den ihr vielleicht auch noch ein paar aus Deutschland kennen, genau, ehemaliger Feiernstürmer, der hat sich die Zeit genommen und hat ihn ja durch Trigoria geführt, durchs Roma-Zentrum. Und da wurden halt immer wieder quasi so kleine Fragmente, an die konnte er sich erinnern, ah ja, das war ja die Bartolomeo, damals der Roma-Kapitän, wenn er Bilder gesehen hat. Und zum Beispiel, er hat dann Bilder gesehen von Francesco Totti und er kannte Francesco Totti nicht, weil er eben wie gesagt von 1980 bis 2019 sozusagen, ja, seine ganze Erinnerung weg sind. Also wirklich berührend. Die Roma hat das halt auf Social Media auch begleitet. Und der ältere Herr, jetzt fällt mir der Name nicht ein, hat halt echt gesagt, was schön ist, er hat gesagt, er kann sich wirklich immer noch das meiste nicht erinnern, aber sie haben viel mehr Psychologen jetzt in den letzten Jahren gearbeitet. Und so gewisse Fragmente sind, kommen wieder, Kleinigkeiten und einige davon sind halt mit der Roma verbunden. Deswegen vielleicht eine schöne kleine Weihnachtsgeschichte, dass der Fußball halt eben manchmal auch in so, ja bei so schweren Schicksalen, dann halt auch einen kleinen Grund liefern kann, um was zum Positiveren zu bewegen.
Es ist nicht komplett das gleiche Thema, aber artverwandt. Und ich möchte die Botschaft kurz raussenden. Wenn wir über solche Erinnerungslücken und eben zum Beispiel auch Demenz sprechen, dann ist der Fußball nachgewiesenermaßen tatsächlich etwas, was oft Menschen helfen kann, die an Demenz erkrankt sind, sich wieder an Dinge zu erinnern, was ja auch ein Stück Teilhabe am Leben bedeutet. Deswegen, es gab dazu schon Studien, irgendwann vor ein paar Jahren habe ich das im Rasenfunk auch schon mal kurz angesprochen, mit, dass eben genau das ist, dass eben gerade Fußballfans, die an Demenz erkranken, dadurch eben ein bisschen Teilhabe erfahren und sich eben wieder an Dinge erinnern, die vorher im Nebel verschwunden waren. Und es gibt verschiedene Vereine. Ich habe es jetzt hier über eine schnelle Recherche, gerade beim FC Bayern zum Beispiel gefunden, die sogenannte Erinnerungskoffer anbieten. Das heißt, wenn ihr eben in eurem Umfeld Demenzerkrankte oder an anderen ähnlichen Erkrankungen leidende Menschen in eurem Umfeld habt, dann informiert euch da mal was, ob es da vielleicht was gibt. Wenn das eben Fußballfans sind, dann kann man eben diese Erinnerungskoffer dann sich ausleihen auf eine Art und Weise und eben damit ein paar schöne Stunden vielleicht verbringen wieder mit den Betroffenen. Deswegen wollte ich das hier kurz ansprechen. Ich verlinke jetzt mal das, was ich dazu gefunden habe, aber dass der Fußball da eine große Rolle spielen kann, ist absolut schon nachgewiesen und das sollte man vielleicht auf dem Schirm haben, wenn es einen Leiter dann vielleicht im Umfeld betrifft. Also sehr schöner Hinweis. Vielen Dank, Christian. So, dann gehen wir noch ein letztes Mal nach England. Uli, was hast du für uns?
Nichts Neues, aber er muss einfach genannt werden. Hinten raus in dem Jahr Cole Palmer ist eine Sensation. Deswegen bitte kudos to him. Hat die meisten Torbeteiligungen für Chelsea in einem Kalenderjahr. Jimmy Floyd Hasselbank abgelenkt. Auch deswegen, da bin ich ganz ehrlich, dass der Name auch mal hier fällt. Das ist einfach Wahnsinn. Cole Palmer ist wahrscheinlich das nächste am sportlichen Christiano Ronaldo, was wir je gesehen haben, weil der einfach manchmal den Ball packt und Dinge ermöglicht, von denen du denkst, es geht nicht. Und der Reiß des Spiels so an sich hat, dieser Name Cole Palmer, oder inzwischen finde ich viel besser als Karma, oder Calma, auch Spanisch, das ist wirklich so. Der steht halt einfach da, kann das Spiel drehen gegen Tottenham und macht halt logischen Panenka. Ist klar. Und dann auch danach, es ist jetzt nicht so, dass er sich einen grinst oder so, sondern geht halt einfach stoisch weiter und macht halt weiter sein Ding. Ist wirklich ein fantastischer Fußballer. Deswegen, und auch Chelsea jetzt im Moment zweiter, gibt jetzt die Diskussion in England, ist Chelsea zurück oder nicht? Soweit würde ich jetzt noch nicht gehen wollen. Wahrscheinlich wird Chelsea nie wieder zurückkommen in der Art und Weise, wie wir sie kannten, sondern eben auf ihre Art und Weise. Aber für Platz zwei hat Cole Palmer große Verantwortung.
Uli, in die Richtung demnächst bitte auch mal ein bisschen mehr zu Chelsea, auch zu Enzo Maresca, hab jetzt auch vieles aus Italien mitbekommen dazu. Also ich glaube auch spannend, weil ich glaube, der hat da auch einiges in die gute Bahn gelenkt, was bei Chelsea in den letzten Jahren nicht selbstverständlich war.
Unglaublich. Also Maresca hab ich als einer der Top-5-Trainer der Liga im Moment. Das sieht von Spiel zu Spiel besser aus und wie du sagst, auch da ein kommunikativer Aspekt. Der macht es zwar eher auf eisige Art und Weise, aber das ist wahrscheinlich genau das, was die gebraucht haben bei Chelsea, dass der einfach mal sagt, komm, Schluss jetzt mit der Show hier. Ich hol mir jetzt mal die 24 Leute, die ich brauche und der Rest von denen will ich auch nie wieder irgendwas sagen.
Von der 52.
Genau, der andere Bus, dem hat man im Navigationssystem was Falsches eingestellt.
Hilf dem noch so bei Brückwärts einparken und dann geht's los. Trainingsgruppe 2 und 3 sind hier, Leute. Also Schluss mit der Show. Schluss mit der Show ist jetzt tatsächlich auch an dieser Stelle. Und sofern nicht noch irgendwelche unvorhergesehenen Dinge passieren, wahrscheinlich auch mit der internationalen Ligatur. In diesem Sinne danke ich euch vieren, stellvertretend für alle Gäste, die wir in diesem Jahr hatten. Es hat ganz fantastisch viel Spaß gemacht nach dem Feedback, was ich bekommen habe, auch den Hörern und Hörern. Also ganz herzlichen Dank, stellvertretend für alle anderen an Uli Hebel, an Nies Kern, an Christian Bernhardt und Daniel Zander. Top Verstärkung, mega cool, dass wir jetzt immer mal wieder auch die Niederlande mit dabei haben. Und wenn ich sehe, wie da auch die anderen aufblühen, wenn über Alkmaar gesprochen wird, da denke ich mir schon, meine Güte, was haben wir liegen lassen in den vergangenen Jahren? Aber jetzt ist es ja da. Also danke euch vieren. Schön, dass ihr mit dabei wart.
Gerne, danke. Danke. Danke ja auch. Schöne Weihnachtszeit noch.
Die wünsche ich allen anderen auch bei schöner Wärme in der eigenen Bleibe. Und ich danke natürlich auch euch lieben Hörerinnen und Hörern für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Und ihr wisst ja, alles hier ist Werbe, Paywall und Sponsoren frei. Wir finanzieren uns ausschließlich über eure freiwillige Unterstützung auf rasenfunk.de/supportersclub. Da erfahrt ihr, wie man uns unterstützen kann. Und in dieser Folge möchte ich mich bedanken bei Till, Seppl, Seba bei Hossa77, bei Florian, bei Tuoboris und bei Thomas Marks. rasenfunk.de/supportersclub. Jeder Betrag hilft und es geht auch etwas an unsere Gäste. Vielen herzlichen Dank, dass ihr die Ligatur in diesem Jahr so fleißig gehört habt. Empfehlt uns sehr gerne weiter. Bleibt uns gewogen und vor allem bleibt gesund. Bis bald hier im Rasenfunk. Macht's gut.
Ciao.
Der Rasenfunk lebt von euren Beiträgen. Vielen Dank.